[Music]
back then
the problem was that a university of
western ontario psychologist named
philippe rushton
had come out with some papers and some
books in which he
said and tried to defend the claim that
blacks are less intelligent more
lascivious
and less family oriented than whites who
are less intelligent
more lascivious and less family oriented
than asians
so this was uh the upshot of his of his
research
and um there were cries
from many quarters that he'd be fired
from his position that's do asians
do asians include brown people just so
that i know just like indians
i have no idea i like followers i want
to know where i stand on this
uh you're indian right well my
background like 200 years ago i'm from
trinidad so
yeah west indian yeah yeah yeah so now
you count as a
caucasian for the purposes of russians
stocks um and of course there are all
sorts of exceptions right ashkenazi
jews um native americans you know so
it's all over the place
and um i have no interest in defending
russian i don't in fact
understand his work at all it's not an
interest of mine
but what does matter to me is that he
was uh
persecuted by members of the government
um and
the premier of ontario at the time david
peterson uh
was agitating for his removal as a
psychology professor from the university
of western ontario now
that's a violation of academic freedom
academic freedom is supposed to protect
people who have even
views that might be considered
pernicious
how about the grievance studies does
academic freedom protect them because i
know some people are advocating for
the demolishment of them because of the
grievance studies because what they do
is not
let's say tenable when it comes to how
the other
fields of university legitimate their
studies
yeah um i i think that the professors in
grievance studies whatever they are are
and should be free to conduct research
and
disseminate the results of their
research uh
uh i i don't think that uh there there
ought to be institutional pressures
against them
now if their work is shoddy it should be
criticized and one of the um
qualities of academic freedom is that we
academics have a responsibility
to engage in critical discussion with
our colleagues especially if we think
that they're mistaken or trite
or whatever so um i i embrace the
critical discussion of grievance studies
but i don't think there should be
institutional forces against grievance
studies now if um
professors and students move away from
these departments then
those resources the university might
decide to use those resources in
in other ways and that's that's for them
to do uh but no
grievance studies departments ought not
be shut down just because
people are dissatisfied or dislike
what's coming from them
what about it that it's not just because
people are dissatisfied but because the
arguments they put forward are species
and they don't do the work that they
purport to do and it's not
how about that's good enough for now how
about for that reason i'm not advocating
for it i'm well yeah no no no no
but that's uh let us criticize
uh uh for that and uh if uh the the
scholars in those areas changed their
minds
so much the better for the uh for the
work of critical discussion
uh but no one should be i don't well
they're free to but
uh i hope no one acts on it people
shouldn't be calling
for the um uh for the departments to be
dissolved or for them to
change their minds whatever and get in
there and argue and
show them that the evidence is such that
one or another claim that they're making
isn't a proper claim
[Music]
you